[SQUEAKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER: So
today, we're going
to continue our discussion
of equity and efficiency.
We started last time talking
about the equity-efficiency
trade-off.
Well, first we
talked about why we
think redistribution
might be necessary,
and the striking facts
on inequality and poverty
in the US.
Then we talked
about the trade-off,
the equity-efficiency
trade-off, and the fact
that when you try to deal with
a problem like redistribution
through taxation or
transfers, you're
going to have a leaky bucket.
That there's going to be
inefficiencies associated
with both taxing individuals
to raise the money,
and transferring to
individuals to spend the money,
are both going to
cause deadweight loss.
So what I want to
to today is take
that abstract framework
from last time,
put it in some real terms.
By talking first about how
taxation works in the US,
and the kind of issues we face
in taxing people, and then
turning to
redistribution programs.
And concluding with
a very positive story
of what I call a patch
to the leaky bucket,
and how we can redistribute
in a very efficient way.
So let's start by talking
about taxation in the US.
And when I talk
about taxation, I
want to talk about
two topics primarily.
The first topic is,
who bears taxes?
Who bears taxes?
Now, this is a
topic that we call--
in public finance, the field
I specialize in-- the topic
of tax incidence.
Now, you might think
this is a silly question.
If you pay tax,
you bear the tax.
Why is this an
interesting question?
And the answer is, it's
an interesting question
because it's not true that
the person that bears the tax
pays the tax.
That in fact, when
you impose taxes,
they have complicated effects
on multiple parties because
of the operation of the market.
So as a result, the party
that actually sends the check
to the government may not
actually bear all that tax.
And so that's the interesting
insight we'll start with today.
So to think about that, let's go
to figure 22-1, and let's think
about the market for gasoline.
You've got demand and supply.
You've got an initial 100
billion gallons of gas being
sold at a price of $1.50.
Those were the days,
back when gas was $1.50.
Now, imagine the government
comes in and says,
we're going to levy a $0.50
tax per gallon on the suppliers
of gasoline.
So the gas stations, or the
gas companies, or whatever.
For every gallon they sell,
they will send us $0.50.
You literally cut a
check to the government,
$0.50 for every gallon you sell.
What does that do--
and you might stop
there and say, OK, well,
then the incidence
of that tax is--
that tax is borne by producers.
That's great.
I don't have to worry about it.
I'm buying gas.
It's those guys selling
gas who have to bear it.
But you'd be wrong.
And the reason you'd
be wrong is shown
in the right-hand-side
diagram, which
is to think through the market
effect of such intervention.
What does intervention do?
Well, it has no effect
on the demand for gas.
The fundamental demand curve.
The underlying utility of
the marginal gallon of gas
hasn't changed.
But it has changed
the supply curve,
because essentially, we've
introduced a new marginal cost.
The marginal cost of gas has
gone up by $0.50 a gallon.
Every gallon of gas you produce
and sell now bears an extra
$0.50 cost.
So that's a shift upward
of the supply curve.
Remember, the supply curve
is the marginal cost curve.
So if I increase the marginal
cost of every gallon by $0.50,
that's literally just a parallel
shift upwards in the supply
curve.
Supply curve shifts
from S1 to S2.
That's the new supply curve.
Well, at that new supply curve,
you cannot continue to charge
the old price.
If you can charge the
old price of $1.50,
people would still want to buy
100 billion gallons of gas,
but companies would only want
to sell 80 billion gallons.
Why?
Because the marginal
cost has gone up.
And we have an
upward-sloping supply curve,
so at a higher
marginal cost, they're
going to want to
sell fewer gallons.
So you have a disequilibrium.
What happens is that the gas
company adjusts by sliding up
the supply curve to the
new equilibrium point D,
where they sell 90 billion
gallons at a new price
of $1.80.
This is all just standard
supply and demand stuff,
we've seen that before.
What's interesting
here is to note
that what this means
is that part of the tax
is borne by consumers.
Part of the tax is
borne by consumers.
What I mean by that?
What I mean is consumers
used to pay $1.50 a gallon,
and now they pay $1.80 a gallon.
So the tax has increased what
they pay by $0.30 a gallon.
Now, they're not sending
that check to the government,
but it's the same thing.
It's the same effect.
The point is this tax has
increased the amount that
consumers pay for gas
by $0.30 a gallon.
So the incidence on
consumers is $0.30.
The incidents on producers
is a little more complicated.
They now get $1.80 per gallon.
That's great.
But for every gallon they sell,
they have to send a $0.50 check
to the government.
So their net price
per gallon is $1.30.
So we can see that by taking
the new price at point D
and subtracting off the
$0.50 tax they have to pay,
which says that instead
of $1.80, they get $1.30.
We call that the tax wedge.
The tax wedge is the difference
between the tax including
the price and the tax
after paying the price.
So it's just a
wedge between what
people get before
they pay the tax
and what they get
after paying the tax.
That's the tax wedge.
We have a $0.50 tax wedge here.
And so what is the burden
of the tax on producers?
Well, they used to
get $1.50 a gallon.
Now they get $1.80 but pay
$0.50 to the government.
So the burden on the
producers is $0.20.
So even though the producers
are sending the check
to the government--
the gas stations,
the gas companies sending
the check to the government,
they actually pay less
than half the tax.
Now, nominally,
they pay the $0.50,
but we don't care about that.
We just care about
where they end up
after the market is adjusted.
After the market is adjusted,
they are $0.20 per gallon worse
off than they were before.
And consumers are $0.30 per
gallon worse off than they were
before.
This is the fundamental
insight of tax incidence,
that you can't just
look at the paper
version of who pays the tax.
You have to consider
who really bears
the consequences of the tax.
And that's why it
gets interesting.
Because the party that bears the
consequences is not necessarily
the party that actually sends
the check to the government.
That's the fundamental
insight of tax incidence.
Questions about
how that all works.
OK.
So bottom line is all you do is
you say, look, think about how
the tax affects the market.
In this case, it's an upward
shift in supply curve.
Shift the supply curve up.
Find the new equilibrium.
That gives you the
new equilibrium price.
And then the burden on the
party not paying the tax
is the difference between the
new price and the old price.
The burden on the
party paying the tax
is the new price minus
the tax they have to pay.
OK?
Now, what's
interesting about this
is that within this framework--
so the first bold claim
I'm going to make is,
actually, it doesn't
matter who sends the check
to the government.
The first bold claim--
let me tell you about it.
The first bold claim
I'm going to make
is that the amount set on
the check to the government
is not the amount you
actually bear of the tax.
The amount you bear of the tax
comes out of this analysis.
Here's the second bold
claim I'm going to make.
It doesn't matter who sends
the check to the government.
If you impose the same $0.50 tax
on consumers of gas in the same
market, you get
the same outcome.
How's that possible?
Well, let's look at figure 22-2.
Now we have a different tax.
This tax is now every time
you buy a gallon of gas,
you pay $0.50.
Imagine the outcry.
Imagine if the government had
a tax which made gas companies
pay $0.50 of a gallon they sold,
and they said, you know what,
we're just going to switch that
and make people pay the $0.50.
Could you imagine the headlines?
The outcry?
Government screwing the little
guy to favor the oil companies.
But in fact, those headlines
would all be wrong.
Because in fact,
it doesn't matter.
To see why, let's look
at the diagram 22-2.
Now imagine we have a
$0.50 tax on consumers.
Now the supply curve doesn't
shift because marginal cost
hasn't changed.
But the demand
curve shifts down.
Because for every
gallon you buy,
you have to send $0.50
to the government.
Well, the demand curve
represents your willingness
to pay.
You are now willing to
pay $0.50 less per gallon.
If you're willing to
pay before at point A,
the 100 billionth gallon sold,
they're willing to pay exactly
$1.50.
Well, if they only pay
$1.50 and now you send $0.50
to the government, well, now
they're only willing to pay $1
for that gas.
So what that means
is consumers now,
with the shifting demand curve,
if the price stayed at $1.50,
they would only want 80
billion gallons at point C.
They would only want 80 billion
gallons at a price of $1.50.
Why?
Because the price to
them isn't $1.50 anymore.
They pay the $1.50,
plus they pay the $0.20.
They'd have to pay another
$0.50 check to the government.
So they only want--
so to them, they don't
want 80 billion gallons.
So you have to move
to a new equilibrium.
Once again, we know
about these adjustments.
We talked about that.
You're going to slide
down the supply curve,
and you're going to end
up at a new point D.
D is the new equilibrium
where the new demand
curve, reflecting the much
lower willingness to pay,
intersects the supply curve.
That point, interestingly,
is at 90 billion gallons.
Flip the page back to 22-1.
That's the same
quantity we had before.
So we get the same effect
on the amount of gas sold.
What's the difference
is the market price.
In 22-1, the market
price rose to $1.80.
Now, the market
price falls to $1.30.
But the burdens are the same.
Think about the burden
on the consumer.
The consumer used to pay $1.50.
Now they pay $1.30.
So they saved $0.20.
But they have to send a $0.50
check to the government.
So the burden on the
consumer is $0.30.
They save $0.20 on the
price and send a $0.50 check
to the government.
What's the burden on producers?
Well, the producers
used to get $1.50.
Now they get $1.30.
So what's the burden
on producers? $0.20.
Same as before.
The point is for
any given total tax
wedge, for any given
total amount of tax,
who bears it does not
depend on who sends
the check into the government.
That's irrelevant.
The side of the
market's irrelevant.
All that matters is
the underlying demand
and supply curves and the
size of the tax wedge.
As long as you
have an underlying
set of supply and demand curves
and a given size tax wedge,
you don't care
who actually pays.
Because the market will
adjust to offset that.
And so this is an
incredible insight
of tax incidence, which
is that something--
I'd imagine most of you
walk in this room today,
and I quickly said to you, does
it matter if the gas company
pays $0.50, you pay $0.50,
you'd say, yeah, it matters.
But it turns out it doesn't.
Turns out it doesn't.
As long-- given
a given tax wedge
and given a set of
supply and demand curves,
it doesn't matter
who actually pays.
And that's the fundamental--
it's another fundamental side
of tax incidence.
And that's why, when
you read articles
in the paper about this tax
is bad because it's on people,
this tax is good because
it's on corporations, that's
not the way to think about it.
The way to think about it is
what's the total tax wedge,
and what does the
market look like?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Excellent point.
All of this, of course, is
within our standard 14.01
framework.
Once you depart from that--
by the way, it's also true even
if there's monopoly and stuff.
That's still true.
So this does not depend on
perfectly competitive markets.
This is also true in
non-perfectly competitive
markets.
So monopoly, oligopoly will
still feature these two rules.
However, once you depart from
perfectly rational consumers,
then things can change.
So for example, there's a
lot of interesting research
on what's called tax salience.
And as I said, since
I won't have time
for a lecture on behavioral
economics this semester,
I'm going to throw some
behavioral economics
nuggets at you.
But if you find this
interesting, take 14.13.
It's really exciting.
And here's a kind
of insight, which
is, what if people pay
attention to taxes when
it's in the price, but not when
it's rung up at the register?
So they ran a cool experiment
in supermarkets in California.
They randomly, in some
cases, increased the price
on the shelf by the sales tax.
In other case, they
kept the price fixed,
and the sales taxes
rang up at the counter,
like we normally do.
And they found that
affected demand.
That affected how much
people wanted the good,
even though the net price
was the same, because it
was more salient when it
was built into the price
than when it's like at the
end, when you just ring it up,
you don't pay attention to it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
research as to whether when
the consumer knows that
they're being taxed rather
than the producer, if that
changes how the demand function
works [INAUDIBLE].
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that's exactly what I said.
That's exactly what--
there's two questions.
One is how this affects
the demand curve.
That's what I was saying.
That basically,
the demand curve--
it's not quite your question.
Your question's about
sort of a moral,
like, do I feel differently
if one's being taxed another--
or you're talking about
the salience point?
AUDIENCE: Maybe like
a little bit of both,
just how people react
when they know for a fact
that they're paying the tax--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah.
I think we don't know for
sure the moral aspect.
But the salience aspect, we
do know for sure, which is,
how the tax is presented
affect people's demand,
even though it shouldn't.
Now, there's another
question which
I thought you were
going to ask, which
is, how does the fact
that you can see a tax
affect how people
feel about taxes?
So here's a super cool study my
colleague Amy Finkelstein did.
You guys know E-ZPass, the
thing on the highway where you--
OK.
So when states moved--
when I was a kid,
you just wait in line
and pay cash to get
through the tolls.
Now you just drive
through with your E-ZPass.
So what's happened is it
made the tax less salient.
It used to be you'd
feel pain every time
you go through the toll.
Now it's just some bill you
get at the end of month.
What she found is when
states switched to E-ZPass,
they rapidly raised
their taxes on roads.
They raised their tolls,
because people in mind as much,
so they could raise them more.
So there's an interesting
politics aspect to this
as well.
So this matters.
Having said that, I'm
going to ignore it.
But this stuff does
matter, and that's
why behavioral economics
is fascinating.
OK?
Now, there's a third point
I want to make about taxes.
So I talked about
who bears taxes.
I talked about the
side of the market.
Side of the market
is irrelevant.
And then the third point
I want to make about taxes
is it's all about
the elasticities.
Which is, who bears a tax?
For a given tax wedge,
who bears the tax
is all determined
by the elasticities
of supply and demand curve.
And in particular, inelastic
parties get stuck with taxes,
while elastic
parties avoid taxes.
So inelastic agent, inelastic
firms, inelastic consumers,
they get stuck with
taxes, while elastically
supplied firms, or
elastically demanded goods,
they avoid taxes.
So to see that, let's
look at figure 22-3.
Let's go back to our tax on
the suppliers of gasoline.
Once again, I hope
you know by now
it wouldn't matter if
demanders of gasoline.
But it's a little easier to
see with suppliers of gas,
so let's go back to our
tax suppliers of gasoline.
So we have a supply curve
that's been shifted up by $0.50.
Let's consider two markets,
one with perfectly inelastic
demand, one with
perfectly elastic demand.
In the market, it was
perfectly inelastic demand.
We used to sell 100 billion
gallons at a price of $1.50.
Now we levy a $0.50
tax on suppliers.
Where do we end up?
We end up still selling
100 billion gallons of gas.
You have to, because inelastic.
Well, if you're
going to still sell
100 billion gallons of
gas, then the suppliers
can't bear any of the tax.
They have to be able to fully
pass the tax onto price.
That is, they have to
be able to charge $2.
Think of the logic.
Suppliers have to be
on their supply curve.
The supply curve has
just shifted up by $0.50.
Therefore, if you're going
to sell the same quantity,
the price must go up by $0.50.
So in that case,
who bears the tax?
Who bears this tax on gas?
Someone raise their
hand and tell me.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Consumers.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Consumers bear all of it.
Consumers bear all the
tax, suppliers bear none.
The supplier, you sent--
you just sent a $0.50
check to the government,
but you're getting $0.50 higher
price, so you don't care.
Insert 50 Cent joke here.
In the gas?
I don't know you
do a 50 Cent joke.
Whatever.
OK.
So you don't care.
Now let's flip the case.
Let's imagine demand for
gas is perfectly elastic.
Now, the supply curve
has shifted up by $0.50.
Supply curve was
shifted up by $0.50.
Now what happens is
consumers say, look,
I don't care how you
feel, Mr. Supplier,
I'm not paying more
than $1.50 for gas.
I have perfectly elastic demand.
Supplier has no choice, then,
but to eat the whole tax.
Because if they try to pass
any of it onto the consumer,
the consumer will bolt. So
the new equilibrium is that--
where the price stays
the same of $1.50,
and the quantity falls.
In this case, the producer
bears the whole tax.
The consumer pays no
more than it did before.
The gas company gets the
same price it did before,
but has to send a $0.50
check to the government.
So the entire burden is
borne by the producer.
What is going on?
Why would inelastic demand--
what's the intuition here?
So with inelastic
demand, consumers end up
getting stuck with the tax.
And with elastic demand,
consumers avoid it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: With elastic
demand, consumers
are willing to pay any price,
so if the producers want
to put all of the tax on
them, they can, and consumers
can't do anything about it.
But if you [INAUDIBLE]
elastic demand,
then they can go anywhere
else to get gas at $1.50.
So if you raise your
price, then they're
just not going to buy it.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Right.
Exactly.
I like to think of this--
that's a very good explanation.
I like to think in terms of
almost like negotiating power.
It's not the right
way to think about it,
but I think it's
useful intuition.
That when you've got
inelastic demand,
you've got no negotiating power.
You just want insulin.
You're going to pay
anything for insulin.
So the supplier
knows that, so it's
going to make you
pay the whole tax.
It doesn't matter if you send
the check to the government
or he sends the check
to the government,
he's going to pass
the whole cost to you.
But if you think
about fast food,
if you think about
a tax on hamburgers,
if you're going to charge a
penny more for hamburgers,
I'm going to buy a hot
dog or a slice of pizza.
Then the supplier
knows they're screwed.
They have no leverage.
You have all the leverage.
You've all the
negotiating power.
So they can't raise
the price on you.
So the bottom line
is, inelastic factors
get stuck with taxes and
elastic factors avoid taxes.
And that's sort of the
other lesson we get here
as we think about taxation.
So at the end of the
day, all that matters--
if you think about any tax
being imposed in the US,
it's never as simple as
just a gas tax, often
a complicated
giant set of taxes.
You think about simple--
a single tax, all
you need to know
is the elasticities, supply
and demand, and the size
of the tax, and you're done.
You can figure out
who bears the tax.
And the Congressional
Budget Office, for example,
does these exercises
all the time,
and has estimates
of how given tax
changes will affect the income
distribution as a result.
Now-- and actually, there's
a pretty cool study of this.
Let me ask the question.
We have hospital taxes.
We have-- hospital.
We have hotel taxes.
I've got too much health
care on the brain.
We've got hotel taxes
in many major cities.
There's some instance
of a hotel tax.
You can imagine a diagram,
we've got supply demand.
How does the incidence
of the hotel tax
change when Airbnb comes in?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The consumer is
suddenly much more able
to switch around, and so
a lot more of the tax,
or maybe all of it,
is borne by the hotel.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
What you see-- and how
would you test that?
How would you test that?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Comparing prices in
areas with different taxation
rates?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
What you find is
when Airbnb comes in,
hotel taxes are passed
less onto price.
Hotel owners are more
bearing the taxes
compared to consumers, because
consumers are more elastic.
So that's an example
of how this can matter.
OK.
So now, let me say one
other thing about taxes.
The last thing I want to say
about taxes is what to tax.
And this is a fundamental
debate that goes back
to the 17th century,
which is essentially,
should we tax people based
on what they produce?
That is, their income.
Or should we tax people
based on what they consume?
Their consumption.
The philosopher Thomas
Hobbs in, like, 17-whatever,
talked about, why
should we tax people
based on the fruits
of their labor?
Let's tax them based on what
they take out of society--
that is, what they consume.
And this is a debate economists
have had for centuries.
Should we tax
consumption or income?
This debate, which shows in the
real world, because in Europe,
they rely much more on
consumption taxes than we do.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wait, would it matter?
JONATHAN GRUBER: I'm going
to tell you why it matters.
So in Europe, they rely much
more on consumption taxes
than we do.
So in the US, most of our
taxes come from income tax,
and in Europe, a lot
of their tax revenue
comes from what's called
the value added tax.
And if you've
traveled in Europe,
you'll know about
the value added
tax, which is a form of
consumption taxation.
So this is a debate that plays
at international-- in the US,
we have sales taxes,
but they're quite
small as a share of revenues
compared to European nations.
Now, why do we care?
Well, we care because
the following equation.
y, your income, can either
be spent on stuff or saved.
Your income can either be
spent on stuff or saved.
And as I talked about
a few lectures ago,
savings is a major engine
of growth in the economy.
More savings means a
broader pool of capital.
Means a broader pool
of capital, which
means a lower interest
rate, which means
firms can invest more.
So we like promoting
savings in the long run.
In the short run,
in a recession,
we may feel differently.
But in the long run, we
like having more savings.
So in the long run, we
If you tax income, you tax both
my consumption and my savings.
If you tax my consumption,
then you don't tax my savings.
That is, you relatively favor
savings over consumption.
You promote people to save
rather than consuming.
So that's why many economists--
I think probably if you
did a poll of economists
and said, should be tax
income or consumption,
the majority would
say consumption.
And the reason
they would give is
because we need more
savings in society,
and we need to promote that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it be
equivalent to taxing income
and they're giving a
tax break for saving?
JONATHAN GRUBER: That would
be identically equivalent.
If you give a 100% tax credit
for all of your savings,
that would be identical.
Now, in the US, we have
some partial credits
like that, but far from 100%.
So the question is, what's
the counterargument?
Well, the counterargument
is all about fairness.
Which is that it turns out that
the rich save and nobody else
does.
Basically almost all
the savings in society
is done by the top probably
10% of individuals in society.
And the bottom 50% of
individuals in society
have basically no savings.
So essentially, what this
means is for most Americans,
for the typical
American, this debate
is irrelevant, because
they have no savings.
You tax their income, you
tax their consumption,
it's the same thing.
For rich Americans, it'd
be a much better deal
to tax consumption,
because they have savings
that then wouldn't be taxed.
So the problem with the
consumption tax base,
it'll mean a massive
redistribution from the poor
to the rich, because the
rich folks do the savings.
Now, there would
be a simple answer
to-- there would be
an answer to this.
We could answer this, because
ultimately, the rich folks die.
It doesn't matter how rich
they are, they die eventually.
And if at that point, we
taxed all their savings,
we could then equalize things.
So in other words, if we took
all the money that was left--
let's say we had
this consumption tax,
but we counted its
consumption the money
you left behind when you died.
Then it would solve the problem,
because the rich would--
during their life,
they'd pay less tax,
but they'd pay it
all at the end.
So that's why we have
a critical debate
in this country
over the estate tax,
or the so-called death tax.
This notion of
whether you should
be taxed on their
estates becomes
very important for
thinking about this.
If we had an estate
tax which was literally
at the same rate
as all other taxes,
then we could move to
taxing consumption.
It would be the same.
In fact, we'd essentially have
a consumption tax at that point.
But in fact, we
have an estate tax
that is paid only by
the top 0.04% of people
who die each year.
And it's paid on only a
fraction of their assets.
So we don't have that.
So that's why the
fairness debate comes in.
So I just want to point
out, just another--
these are all just topics I'm
hitting to whet your appetite.
These are interesting
things we need
to think about when we think
about how to set up our tax
systems, is basically
things like,
do we tax income or consumption?
OK?
Questions about that?
OK.
That's taxes.
Now I want to turn to--
so that's one side of the
equation, which is taxes.
We know they cause
inefficiencies.
deadweight losses.
And we know that there's some
question about who bears them.
But the bottom line
is taxes are putting
some leak in the bucket,
and that's a problem.
The other side of the leak
in the bucket is transfers.
Which is, as we saw in
the diagram last time,
if you essentially condition
my getting money on my working,
I'll work less.
If you say to me,
hey, John, you're
currently making $5,000 a year.
I'm going to give you $10,000
no matter what you do,
but any money you
earn will come off
that $10,000, I'll say
great, I'll just quit.
So the problem with transfers
is they act like taxes.
If you take the transfers and
phase them out, take them away
from people, they
have a similar effect.
In fact, we call
transfers an implicit tax.
[INAUDIBLE] transfer
system from last time,
which is the amount you got was
the max of 0, was the max of 0,
or 10,000 minus your income.
This is essentially 100% tax
rate on everybody's incomes
below $10,000.
Because for every
dollar you earn,
we take it away, because you
get $10,000 no matter what.
So this is a tax, basically.
But in fact, this
tax is unavoidable
if we want to target
money to poor people.
If we just gave everyone
$10,000, it wouldn't be a tax.
We just gave everyone $10,000.
Now, it would impact
how hard people work.
Why?
Why would it impact
how people work?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
logarithmic [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: No, no, I'm
going to labor supply theory.
What's the name of
the effect for why
that would affect [INAUDIBLE]
if we gave everyone $10,000?
The income effect.
So it wouldn't affect
how our people work.
But it wouldn't really
distort people's labors.
We think of distortions that
arise in the substitution
effect.
People making different
decisions because of tax rates.
The reason we get a problem,
the reason we get deadweight
loss is because I'm ta--
not that I'm giving
you $10,000, it's
that I'm taking away
as you get richer.
That's the problem.
So then the question is,
what can we do about this?
What can we do about the
fact that we're essentially
imposing implicit taxes on poor
people by giving them money?
So there are a couple answers.
The first is
categorical transfers.
That is, instead of giving
the money to everybody,
just give it to
deserving populations.
So for example, one of them--
the largest single cash transfer
program, pure cash transfer
program in the US, is to--
that's literally giving cash is
what's called the SSI program,
the Supplemental
Security Income program.
It's about $80 billion a year.
And what this does
is give cash grants
to low income families that
have disabled children.
So it's not just that
you're low income,
but that you have a disabled
child in your house.
Likewise, we have
something called
the TANF program, which is
what is traditionally called--
I've used the term "welfare" in
this course to mean well-being.
Traditionally in America,
when you say welfare
with a sneer on your face,
you're referring to TANF.
TANF is cash grants to
low-income single-parent
households.
Essentially, if you're low
income and you're a single mom,
typically, you get a
grant from the government.
Now, the question
people have always asked
is, why do we impose
these conditions?
Why do we make people disabled?
Why do we make them
be single moms?
Why don't just give
them the money?
Why not have this?
Why have these other conditions?
And the answer is because--
that basically, we
think this is a way
of reducing the distortion
that arises from transfers.
Think of it this way.
Imagine all of us
were born with,
on our forehead, an
unremovable tattoo that
said "hardworking and lazy."
No, let's not do that.
Different thing.
Let's do "low skill
and high skill."
So I know your
underlying ability.
Then I would simply say,
look, if you're high skill,
you don't get any money.
I don't care if you're poor.
If you're poor, it
just means you're lazy,
because I know
you're high skill.
If you're low skill, I'm
going to give you money.
And that would not
distort behavior at all,
because people couldn't
change what's on their head,
so they would just continue
to work as hard as they always
worked.
This is the idea of trying
to find signals like that.
You're trying to find
ways of identifying
the people who need the help.
And by doing so--
who need the help,
but need the help
in a way that's
not changed by their behavior.
We think that a
kid being disabled,
they didn't choose
to be disabled.
Or mom being single
mom, she didn't
choose to be a single mom.
That starts to get a
little more interesting.
So essentially, the idea
of categorical welfare
is to basically say, can
we find things about people
that they didn't choose on which
we can base giving them money?
So blindness is a good
example, et cetera.
Now, the question that then
raises, well, can people
choose these things?
Well, you might say,
well, of course,
a kid can't choose
to be disabled,
but people can choose
to be single moms.
In fact, the evidence
is the opposite.
Let me explain what I mean.
If you give people money
tied to being a single mom,
it doesn't cause them
to be a single mom.
The evidence is
very clear on that.
So there have been
hundreds of studies showing
that paying women money
conditional on being
a single mom doesn't cause
them to get divorced or have
kids out of wedlock.
That's been clear.
But if you give family money
based on kids being disabled,
more disabled kids show up.
Why?
Because disability is a
tough thing to assess.
Most disabilities are
musculoskeletal or mental,
and those are hard
things-- you can
tell if a kid's missing
a limb, but it's
hard to evaluate truly
musculoskeletal or mental
disabilities.
And interestingly,
despite your intuition
what it might've been
a few minutes ago,
the place where in subsets we
see the most people changing
their behavior to qualify--
at least changing behavior
meaning not becoming disabled,
but claiming they're disabled--
is here and not in
single motherhood.
So categorical
transfers help, but not
as much as you might think,
because the categories
are hard to measure.
And that's why
another tool we've
used to try to get at
this is in-kind transfers.
In-kind transfers.
OK.
Part of the problem--
yeah, Manny.
AUDIENCE: For the
TANF, does it account--
when it says for
single parents, does it
account for people that
live in the household?
So like--
JONATHAN GRUBER: It's
a great question.
That's a tricky thing
to have to deal with,
which is how do you deal
with co-residing people?
And that's something they have a
complicated set of rules about.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
stuff you didn't choose thing,
because they seem to try to
simplify the cons [INAUDIBLE]
choose, whereas I
think in real life,
it's probably related to the
circumstances of your birth--
JONATHAN GRUBER: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --and other
stuff like that.
And so is it possible that these
indicators are making it worse
for people who are in situations
where they couldn't have
avoided being in
poverty, but they
happen to not be a single
mom or not be disabled?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Awesome question.
And so basically,
here's the trade-off.
Okay, give me a better
way to teach it.
Here's the trade-off.
The trade-off is,
the more you target--
let's say I said I'm going
to replace our entire welfare
system in America with just
transfers to the blind.
And let's assume people don't
blind themselves to get money.
You laugh, but there
is a city in Florida
where they found that over
a certain period of time,
the vast majority of US
claim for lost limbs came
from one city in Florida.
And it turned out that
people were actually
cutting off their limbs to
qualify for government money.
They actually
called it Nub City.
So you laugh.
This stuff does happen.
But by and large, we
assume it doesn't.
OK, so let's say I want to
replace the entire US welfare
system with one just for
people who are blind.
On the one hand,
that'd be great,
because you wouldn't
cause any distortion.
People shouldn't work any
less hard because you can't
change whether you're blind.
On the other hand, you'd
leave all of these people
out in the cold who need help.
So that's the trade-off, which
is the broader you spread it--
the more you move toward
a universal system,
the more potential distortion
you cause in terms of people
changing their work behavior,
but the broader set of people
you can help.
And that's why
there's a big move now
for what's called universal
basic income, UBI.
It's a big movement now
around the world to say, look,
forget these things, SSI, TANF.
They're all messy to measure.
They're stigmatizing.
People can change them anyway.
Let's just give people money.
And that's sort of one
motivation for that.
Now, but the other way to get
at this that people come at
is, look, the problem
all here is a simple one,
which is everyone loves money.
Rich or poor, we all love money.
But what if what we gave
people was not money,
but things that poor people
need and rich people don't?
Like for example,
mediocre public housing.
Not a mansion, but an apartment.
A rich person isn't
going to pretend
they're poor to get
a crappy apartment
or a mediocre apartment.
But a poor person who'd
be homeless otherwise
will happily take it.
What about medical care?
Rich people have private
health insurance.
They don't need
government medical care.
Poor people need
What about food stamps?
Rich people can afford food.
Poor people can't.
So the idea is basically,
by giving in-kind transfers,
like medical care,
or housing, or food,
we get people to what we call
self-reveal that they're poor.
Here the problem is
people might pretend
they're poor to get the money.
They might quit.
Even if they can afford
to work, they might quit.
Here we say, well, look, you're
not going to quit your job
to get a mediocre--
you guys with your--
make it 100 grand
a year at MIT, I'm
going to quit your jobs to get
some mediocre public sector
apartment.
But if I said I'll give you 100
grand whether you work or not,
you might quit your job.
But say you live in a
mediocre apartment, you won't.
So the idea, by giving
people in-kind benefits,
is to get them to self-reveal
whether they're actually poor
or not.
Now, that's not the main reason
why giving in-kind transfers.
This is the economist reason.
The main reasons is
because politicians
are what we call paternalistic.
And this comes all the way back.
You guys remember when
we discussed food stamps,
and we did budget
constraints, and I said, well,
we never want to give
people food stamps.
We want to give them money.
And they say, but what if the
[INAUDIBLE] labeled cocaine?
Then we would want to
give them food stamps,
because we don't want them to
spend the money on cocaine.
Well, that's how politicians
feel about poor people.
They feel that poor people,
if you give them money,
will just waste it.
And that's why the vast majority
of transfers we do in America
are in-kind.
If you add up all the
money we give people
in cash versus the
money we give in-kind,
particularly medical care,
the in-kind dollars vastly
outweigh the cash dollars.
And that's because
politicians are paternalistic.
They're afraid-- no.
The economics reason
is because there's
all this model of
self-revelation,
but that's not why
politicians do it.
They do it because
they're worried
people will waste the money
if you give them cash.
And I think we
showed with the food
stamps and the evidence,
that's not really the right way
to think about it.
OK?
Questions about that.
OK.
Now, this is all kind of
negative and nebulous,
so let me conclude with
a great example, which
is an example of a public policy
which actually doesn't stop
the leak in the
bucket, it actually
puts a patch in the bucket.
And that policy is called
the earned income tax credit.
The EITC.
This is what's known as
a conditional transfer.
What that means is it's a
program where you get money,
but the money you get is
a function of how much you
make up to a point.
So it's actually--
the other thing
it's been called
is a wage subsidy.
So here's how the EITC works.
Let's go to figure 22-4.
I'll show you how
the EITC works.
Here's how the EITC works.
For every dollar-- on the
x-axis is how much earned income
you have.
On the y-axis is
the check you're
going to get from
the government.
What this says is on
every dollar you earn,
until you earn $13,870--
these numbers are
a bit out of date.
It's a little more now, but
roughly gives you the idea.
Until you hit $13,870-- that
is roughly the poverty line.
It's a little bit more
than the poverty line.
For every dollar you earn,
the government gives you $0.40
more.
So if you're someone who
starts with $0 and you earn $1,
you take home $1.40.
It's a negative tax.
It's a subsidy.
So every dollar,
you take home $1.40.
Until you reach
earnings of $13,870.
At that point, you've
achieved a check of $5,548.
That's 40% of 13,870.
At that point, the
government says
this is the biggest
check we're sending you,
and we're to keep that flat
until you're at an 18,110.
And then we'll start
to take it away.
We're going to start to take
it away so that by the time--
and what we're
going to do is we're
going to take that 5,548
check down by $0.21 cents
for every dollar you earn.
It's going to flip
from a negative tax
to a positive tax at a 21% rate.
So instead of a negative
tax at a 40% rate,
we switch to a positive tax at
a 21% rate, so that by the time
you've earned $44,454,
you've zeroed out your EITC.
So for most of you, the
EITC will be relevant.
For most of your families,
the EITC is irrelevant.
So it's a targeted
transfer program.
Conditional transfer.
It's conditional
because basically, it's
conditional on working.
But it's targeted in the
sense that it phases out
such that middle class and
upper class people don't get it.
It's targeted to lower-income
people through this phase-out.
The problem is this makes
the EITC effect complicated.
So let's consider.
Let's consider the three
segments of this graph.
Let's start with
the first segment.
Let's say you were
earning zero, and I said,
for every dollar you earn,
I will give you $0.40 more.
What effect does that have on
your labor supply, starting
from zero?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] more
because having a lot of leisure
can cost a lot more.
JONATHAN GRUBER: The
substitution effect
will make you work more, because
essentially, we've raised
the price of leisure by 40%.
What about the income effect?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: There
is no income effect.
So the point is,
for someone at $0,
this unambiguously increased
their labor supply.
So if you take guys who aren't
working, this definitely will--
I mean, it might
be a zero effect,
but it's non-negative
effect on labor supply.
Likewise, with low-income,
working low hours,
the income effect will be small.
Remember, the income effect's
proportional of how much you're
actually earning.
So for these people on
the left-hand segment,
upward-sloping, it should
cause them to work more,
because the substation
effect will be big
and the income
effect will be small.
So if you mark the people
on this left-hand segment,
you should mark
they'll work more.
Now what about people
in the flat segment?
Someone else raise
their hand and tell me.
What's this going to do to
the labor supply of people
on the flat segment?
They're going to
work more or less?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think
they'll work the same,
because it's not like any
change in their earning.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
their wage hasn't changed,
but something has changed.
AUDIENCE: If they're
on the flat part,
they'll work less
because they only
have to work until they make
$13,870 to get [INAUDIBLE]..
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
that's not quite-- that's
an extreme model.
More generally, it's
because of income effects.
More generally, the point is
I've taken someone and made
them $5,000 richer.
So compared to a world
without the EITC--
that's why I show-- compared
to a world without the EITC,
I will now work less.
There's no substitution
effect, only an income effect.
So now I'll work less.
So the first part [INAUDIBLE]
substitution effects.
The second part is
just an income effect.
Now what about
the third segment?
We're assuming
leisure is normal.
Do I work more or less?
Do I work more or less,
assuming leisure is normal?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Less?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Less because?
AUDIENCE: Substitution effect.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Substitution
effect and income effect,
because your income
is falling as--
because the point
is, as you work more,
your income is falling.
So here, both the
subsection and income effect
combine to make you
want to work less.
So if you look at
this graph, this
doesn't look very promising.
On the left, we've got a
bunch of guys working more.
In the middle, we got
guys working less.
And on the other
side, we got guys
working way less, because you
have a substitution and income
effect.
So the question then is, what
effect does the EITC have?
And the answer is it turns out
it has an enormously positive
effect on labor supply.
That it gets a lot of
guys who were working
zero to stop working zero.
But it doesn't seem to lower
the hours among those who are
working more than zero hours.
Now, why is that?
Unclear.
It could be because there's
different elasticities
along the income distribution.
Probably, it's because
of tax salience,
wherever I wrote that.
Wherever the hell I wrote that.
Tax salience, which is that
people understand, gee, if I
go to work, I get a big check.
They don't understand,
by the way,
the marginal hour I work is
being taxed at $0.21 more.
So probably, it's tax
salience, I don't know.
But the bottom line is the
studies show convincingly
that interest in
the EITC massively
increased labor supply and
distribute to the poorest
people in society.
This is a reverse leaky bucket.
Literally, we managed to take
money, give it to poor people,
and make the pie bigger.
So this is an enormous victory
for thinking about how we can--
for getting around
this problem of how
we can transfer to people.
Now, it didn't solve
all our problems
because, [INAUDIBLE]
up here, it doesn't
help people who don't work.
So there's still-- this isn't
the only solution we need,
because some people
literally can't work,
so they can't benefit
from a program like this.
But for workers, this is an
enormously successful program
that is really one of the great
government success stories
in terms of both
transfer to poor people
and increasing the
size of the pie.
All right?
I'm going to stop there,
and so we'll come back--
I'll see you guys on Wednesday.